happy Chinese New Year in case it wasn't
already obvious it is the year of the
fire monkey and in addition to Mexicans
Muslims and uppity blondes the fire
monkey has taken aim at Chinese China
China Chinese China yes the super power
rising in the East is the favorite
scapegoat of the super powder-keg of
this election but it's not clear if it's
contempt or envy Trump insists he knows
China I know China
he loves China I love China he even
wants to build his own great wall along
the border you know the one he'll use
Mexican workers and a Chinese contractor
for in order to keep out the Mexicans
and stick it to the Chinese but the main
thing he wants to do is beat China we
don't win anymore we don't beat China in
trave Trump's called China's economic
relationship to the US the biggest theft
in American history even bigger than
America itself and he wants to put a
huge tax on any Goods coming from the
country even though he himself has been
known to rely on China for his Trump
where China's kind of become the new dog
ate my homework sorry I'm late there was
so much China on the freeway but just
how much can we blame China for
America's struggling economy the US has
lost millions of jobs over the last
couple decades mostly in manufacturing
which can be linked to China especially
after the country entered the World
Trade Organization and the free trade
floodgates opened up China keeps its
manufacturing costs low luring companies
concerned only about their bottom line
to move there there's just too many
bathroom breaks and windows in American
factories but its products are also kept
cheap because its currency is kept low
something you might have heard referred
to as currency manipulation to keep the
dollar stronger China buys up billions
of American dollars and then floods the
economy with cheap you want all that
gives you what's called trade deficit
don't click away that means that the
u.s. buys more from China than China
buys from the US 366 billion dollars
more to be exact what does that mean for
the average American though well you
might have lost your job but you gained
an affordable iPhone 6
the desert bullet that seems fair but
for non average Americans like
corporations and billionaires like
Donald Trump
the trade-off has been much clearer
companies and garment electronics and
retail industries have all profited
big-time off of this trade dynamic take
Apple it only costs them eight dollars
to manufacture an iPhone in China if
they made that same phone in the US it
would cost $73 makes sense that they had
record profits of fifty three point four
billion dollars last year so China might
be beating us economically but that's by
design which I guess means it means
Trump's not wrong okay but like any
toxic relationship quitting cold turkey
is easier said than done if we stop
trade tomorrow there'd be a recession or
if we slapped huge taxes on imports we
could end up with huge consequences and
lately this codependent relationship is
falling apart at the nimbly constructed
by exhausted worker seams manufacturing
has gotten more expensive in China and
their middle class is trying to live the
consumers dream how dare they I guess
the globalized economy is just a wee bit
more complicated than the fire monkey my
leg